land und brecht
[Musik]
guten morgen sichert guttenberg markus
wo erreiche ich dich
auf der yogamatte
wird wunderbar das ist das was ich
eigentlich immer mal hören wollte dass
du mir zu füßen liegt ja aber ich glaub
ich möchte ich fürchte es geht gar nicht
um mich richard ich wollte heute mit dir
mal über ein thema sprechen von dem ich
glaube das ist ein riesiges thema ist da
draußen und ich weiß dass du ein buch
dazu gemacht hast wir haben uns beide
auch schon mal darüber unterhalten ich
sage dir mal ganz kurz zwei eckdaten
7,5 millionen vegetarier gibt es
mittlerweile in deutschland
1,4 millionen menschen leben vegan das
ist viele tendenz jeweils rasant
steigend ja und es gibt den den
herrlichen witz woran erkennt man einen
vegetarier antwort er sagte es dir ja
wann erfüllt sich sozusagen moralisch
überlegen die frage sollten wir fleisch
essen welche rechte sollten tiere haben
was bedeutet das eigentlich wenn wir
deine welt reingehen die zunehmend eine
fleischlose welt wird darüber wollte ich
heute gerne immer mit dir reden und ich
bin dabei auf etwas gestoßen
ich glaube du hast es im vorbeigehen mal
erwähnt aber ich hatte es wieder
verdrängt du wolltest mal zoodirektor
werden ja oh ja und ich war vor ganz
kurzer zeit vor zwei drei wochen zum
ersten mal in meinem leben in den
heiligen hallen das heißt ich war auf
der konferenz der deutschen
zoodirektoren wirklich ja also ich
konnte mich quasi für ein bis zwei
stunden selbst ein bisschen wie ein
zoodirektor fühlen und er zwei direktor
war seit meiner kindheit mein
berufstraum ihre wo findet sowas stadt
richard das fand in diesem fall in
krefeld statt das findet jedes jahr
woanders statt und was wird da wohl ich
war völlig überrascht ich hatte doch so
diese ich hatte mich so in den
neunzigerjahren der zoodirektoren szene
dadurch getummelt dass ich viel über das
geschrieben hat
und ich hatte ihm das waren damals alles
so ältere herren noch zwei direktoren
und auf so nahe mit soll ja noch etwas
altmodischen autorität ausgestattet
jedenfalls viele davon und als ich jetzt
auf der zoodirektoren konferenz war muss
ich feststellen erstaunlich viele fragen
und inzwischen glaube ich glaube ich
dachte immer ja aber früher war das eine
reine männerdomäne ja also ich dachte
immer finanzindustrie stahl fußball und
so die rektoren dass die passionen die
frauen nicht nehmen und
in einigen mag das immer noch so seien
aber tatsächlich gibt es also es
natürlich nicht die mehrheit aber
inzwischen gibt es einige zoodirektorin
was wirklich erstaunlich ist es gibt
eine berühmte legendäre so direktor märz
fielen zwei zoodirektorin ein in der
geschichte der rose im deutschsprachigen
raum es gab vielleicht mehr aber bekannt
wurden meines erachtens nur 2 das war
vor holzapfel in bern und frau ein rot
in berlin und das war beides so 50er
60er jahre und ansonsten bin ich da
immer nur männern begegnet also der zu
ist dermaßen ähnlich gewesen die frauen
haben die tiere versorgt das gab es
immer also wer hat den oder später wie
das heißt tierpflegerinnen das war
häufig weiblich auch schon mal die ein
oder andere zu tierärztin aber die chefs
waren eigentlich immer männer das war es
eigentlich ein klassischer eines
verliebten job interessant ja absolut es
gab auch so in der geschichte weise so
zoodirektoren so der inbegriff von
machos war ja ja das war nicht klar naja
also die berühmten hacks ja gut wie ich
und lutz heck so also der hier berliner
zoo genau was alles inhalt also das
waren richtig also
vierschrötige
machos also so sich dran am
großvenediger ja oder ja ziemlich dicht
dran also der der der der alte heck der
hat sogar man elefanten öffentlich
aufgehängt wow ja es war früher ja so
werden wieder viele falten ein elefant
ein wärter tötet und das kommt sehr sehr
häufig vor ja also elefanten wörter oder
elefantenpfleger leben gefäß ich
wahrscheinlich der gefährlichste beruf
quatsch doch also ich weiterhin aus
versehen sieben taucher oder so aus
versehen oder beide sind sicher die wand
gedrückt oder früher hat man elefanten
ja so gehalten nachdem hands-on prinzip
das heißt man hat die elefanten wilden
gebrochen und die mussten dann quasi
lernen dass der mensch der chef ist und
wenn ein elefant dann irgendwann
herausfindet dass er stärker ist
dann ist dieser elefant im grunde
genommen
dann schickt er nicht mehr nach der
gesicherten sind sehr intelligent und er
ist insofern unberechenbar als dass es
sich ja jetzt nicht mehr fügen muss das
land ja und dann kann das schon mal
passieren also erfanden können
unglaublich zielgenau werfen ja dass ihr
dann so verwende er dann im winter
seinen weihnachtsbaum kriegte er ja
gerne voll vertilgt ja oder die
holzreste darum liegen dass er die den
zielsicher den kopf schmeißt das können
sie sehr sehr gut quatsch doch ganz ganz
gut aber so über viele meter hinweg ganz
genau zielen oder das hätte ich so an
die wand drückt ne in kleinen trupps
übergeben können ein ende sein na ja und
das ist halt so fahrni mit dem bullen
wir nie die macht kommen also wenn ihr
wieder geschlechtsreif sind dann kriegen
die also immer mal so in regelmäßigen
schieben läuft den so eine komische
flüssigkeit aus dem auge und wenn die
über aggressiv das ist wenn dir so
testosteron einschübe haben und da war
das eben in berlin passiert dass der der
elefantenbulle rostock hieß der glaube
ich wenn ich mich richtig erinnere dass
die an den pfleger getötet hat und zur
strafe wurde der öffentlich aufgehängt
ich weiß nicht zur abschreckung für die
anderen elefanten also ich hab keine
ahnung also wir reden jetzt über eine
szene die hundert jahre her so jetzt das
motto sein also noch aus der bösen alten
zeit der zoos ja wir sind uns sehr einig
dass das heute keiner mehr machen würde
aber es war sehr lange ein thema was
macht man mit einem elefanten der im zoo
ist er ein wärter getötet hat und der
nicht mehr integrierbar ist
und was verschiedene schöne geschichte
dazu ist der kölner zoo den ich als sehr
gut kenne im kölner zoo ist ein
elefantenbulle bin du der hat wenn ich
mich recht erinnere zwei
tierpfleger auf dem gewissen und er ist
in einem englischen zoo gehalten worden
unter entsetzlichen bedingungen
und der sollte auch getötet werden
und dann hat der kölner zoo lädt
übernommen waren im kölner zoo gibt es
keine hands on sondern hands off haltung
dh der tierpfleger kommt mit dem tier
nicht mehr in direkten körperlichen
kontakt ja die herde bleibt unter sich
ja es gibt da so ein paar tricks wie man
das machen kann den tier ärztlich zu
versorgen und so hat er aber im prinzip
wird er vom menschen nicht angefasst und
dort ist dieser bindung zu einer seele
von elephant geworden und vater einer
gigantischen schar von kleinen indischen
elefanten wie süß das ist eine richtig
schöne geschichte
und die erwartete überleben war ein
grund doch schon das todesurteil gefällt
aber wenn du mal überlegt was heißt
schon weiter weg ist was wir da für den
paradigmenwechsel erlebt haben der zoo
spiegelt das verhältnis der mensch der
menschen hier ja wirklich ein sondern am
anfang war das auch so dass man klar die
tierhaltung war mit der aller kanone
unter anderem dessen weil man überhaupt
nichts über die tiere wusste ich habe
mich ja mal sehr viel historische
beschäftigt somit die erste
menschenaffen erster gorillas und so die
nicos kam ja also der erste gorilla der
nach deutschland kam der wahlberliner
aquarium da hatte der da so eine ganz
kleine zelle quasi unter drin waren zum
ofen ja damit damit ihm nicht kalt wo er
rauchte und so mancher wurde mit kohle
wurde dass dieser offenbar befeuert mehr
das ein total verrauchte bude das und
das war ja auch früher schrecklich also
wenn man offen für zoos gefangen hat
rücken ja ihre kinder nicht freiwillig
aus und mit erwachsenen kannst du nicht
umgehen dann mussten die ja immer die
ganze familie erschießen um eine junge
anzukommen und das waren ja schon die
sind ja genau so sensibel wie
menschenkinder die sind ja hochgradig
traumatisiert da hingekommen klar ja und
dann wurden die zum teil mit karamell
putin und mit milch gefüttert und so
weil man nicht wusste was sie essen also
das ist eine unglaublich schreckliche
geschichten wirklich ja also gerade
menschenaffen und ich weiß ich habe mit
dirk steffens mal von vielen jahren
darüber gesprochen
und der beschäftigt sich auch sein
ganzes leben lang mit ihren und und
würde wahrscheinlich ähnliche dinge
erzählen liebe grüße über uns an der
stelle und der kies ja ist ja jemand der
der da so einen sondern so ein tiefes
verständnis davon hat was was tiere
eigentlich auch für rechte haben und wie
wir mit ihr umgehen sollten und ich weiß
noch der hatten mehrmals zählt hat mir
berichtet von einem besuch in ruanda die
berühmten nebelwälder und die gorillas
usw
und wir haben wir haben uns über den
genpool von von tieren unterhalten
sagte weißt du wir wir teilen ja 30
prozent unseres genmaterials mit
kohlrabi
50 prozent mit bananen
konnte damals heißt und ganz ehrlich
manchen sieht man es auch an
man ist mehr oder weniger alkohol
und oder mehr oder weniger banane genau
genau und kinos und daher auch der satz
ist ja völlig banale und und du hast
aber
das war eben dann sehr berührt er sagte
er weist und wenn du aber wenn du in
ruanda irgendwo im hochwald auf einen
menschenaffen triffst
sagte das ist immer ganz besonders wenn
du einem löwen in die augen guckst an
dem tiger einem elefanten wem auch immer
da ist immer klar sozusagen zwei
verschiedene spezies aber meinte wenn du
eine menschen ab in die augen gucken
geht es dir kalt den rücken runter weil
beide spüren wir zwei sind sehr eng
miteinander war ja wobei man hinzufügen
sollte dass man das von einem gorilla
niemals tun sollte ja ich weiß nicht ob
das so macht wie weißt du warum
gorillas schauen sich nicht an
gegen zeigen seit allen anderen affen
interessant deswegen haben wir auch den
berühmten spiegel test nicht bestanden
dann hat ja früher spiegel aufgestellt
um zu gucken wie intelligent sind affen
und wollte mal daran festmachen erkennen
die sich im stimmungsbild oder nicht so
bei den gorillas form immer der ansicht
dass toni nicht ja aber selbst wenn der
gründer sich erkennen würde würde er ist
nicht zeigen weil bei google hast das
ist sehr interessant das kann doch jeder
der den affen beobachtet ja also bei
gorillas niemanden sehen ja die sitzen
ja ein bisschen so rum wie kühe thema
und essen den ganzen tag nach so ein
gewaltiger körper der januar pflanzlich
ernährt wird wir müssen müssen ja nicht
den ganzen tag essen und das soziale
schacht dass sie miteinander spielen das
bekommt man wenig mit werden vergleich
zu den action-szenen die da immer bei
schimpansen
bonobos oder so kriegt man eigentlich
relativ wenig mit und das liegt unter
anderem daran dass ihr alle konflikte
vermeiden weil sie sich nicht direkt
angucken ja also da gilt sozusagen der
satz was guckst du ja also direkt an
gucken ist eine totale provokation
interessant kummer das hat das hat sich
auch um gesprochen offensichtlich ja es
gibt auch leute die genau diese
corinna philosophie haben ja nicht
direkt angeguckt werden zu wollen und
darin sofort eine aggression erkennen
das erspart naja man muss ja dazu sagen
nachdem ich das über die zur haltung
gesagt hat na ja also es gab jetzt ein
vortrag auch bei den zoodirektoren das
war ein thema über das wir da auch
diskutiert haben weil menschenaffen
haltung
und natürlich hat sich unglaublich viel
getan also wenn man sich so eine
vorbildliche menschenaffen haltung
anguckt wie die in leipzig zum beispiel
ja das ist so europaweit die beste ist
das vielleicht so weltweit ist ich denke
es ist aber köln ist auch ganz in köln
war nicht in den ohren anfang der 80er
jahre machte google ändert sich eben
sehr sehr schnell also so wie es in köln
ist das war dass das ändert sich ja alle
20 30 jahre sind ja diejenigen die ganz
vorne waren dann ganz hinter mir ja
genau und
was ist so vorbildlich am leipziger zoo
naja also die die sind nicht auf festem
untergrund also nicht auf so ein
kunststoffboden wir sehen das meistens
heute sind sondern die sind tatsächlich
also auch so erde ja das schon ein
großer unterschied dann sind die
dimensionen der freianlagen so riesig
dass man im regelfall keine affen sieht
und man muss immer überlegen jeder affe
hat andere haltungsbedingungen weil er
in anderen sozialen strukturen lebt und
die muss man entsprechend bis zum
beispiel das große probleme beim u tanks
sind eigentlich in der natur
vergleichsweise friedlich da sind so
langsam roten zettel die nerven und bei
denen ist es so die leben nicht in
familienverbänden
sondern die weibchen die streifen so in
so kleinen mädels clubs okay durch die
gegend vor allem wenn sie kinder haben
also treffen sich quasi auf den an den
spielplätzen des regenwaldes ja und
hocken miteinander rum und die männchen
ziehen ziemlich isoliert herum also
jedenfalls dann wenn sie in dem alter
sind dass ihre mutter verlassen
und die sie kriegen also die weibchen
gar nicht so oft zu gesicht wenn man
jetzt im zoo die alle in einer einzigen
anlage hält dann sind die männchen total
reizüberfluteten diesen sozusagen
ständig den weibchen ausgeliefert und
das führt dazu dass sie häufig pervers
werden also aggressiv vergewaltigen und
an die kinder ran gehen ein solcher
sofort los ja natürlich wir sind einfach
völlig völlig überdreht interessant na
ja und das sind so dinge denen man eben
rechnung tragen muss und das kann alles
sachen die man ja früher alles auch
nicht so genau wusste ich würde sagen
also wie lange hat das gedauert na also
ich werde meine meine nächste sendung
mit scheingeld machen ok also der
berühmtesten schimpansenforscherin der
welt und die begann ihre forschung
anfang der 60er jahre und bis dahin
wusste man eigentlich überhaupt nichts
über familienleben sozialen strukturen
von hafen und das spiegelt sich
natürlich in den zoos wieder und da hat
sich jetzt eine menge getan
ich finde es gut wenn ich total
interessant wie die wie die wenden diese
alten videos siehst wie dann diese
schimpansen zum teil dieser scheint
attacken reiten es ist für hasler kennst
das bestimmt nur wenn wenn dann dieses
tier auf die zuschießt mit mit
gefletschten zähnen usw
sie sitzt ganz entspannter weil sie
genau versteht dass das ein angriff ist
das fand ich sehr dass muss man ganz
ganz genau wissen da darf er keinen
fehler erlaubt der bringt dich der bring
dich um 0,6 also ich hab im kölner zoo
gorilla angriffe gesehen da gab es
irgendeinen zoowärter der der war so
früher hätte man gesagt man darf also
vokuhila warten sich nicht breite
schultern und so weiter also der hat
zudem die anhalt.de starker wie man
früher künftig jedes die sozialen
entsprochen war ein netter mensch aber
er hat diese ausstrahlung und weil der
halt diese enorm ähnliche ausstrahlung
aber hatte wurde der von dem
silberrücken der gorillas als
unmittelbare bedrohung empfunden
und der gorilla hat die mehrfach
angegriffen aber dazwischen war eine
glasscheibe und der gorilla greift guckt
nicht an auch beim angriff nicht der
reist als erstes vegetation rausschmeißt
david rum und galoppiert dann seitlich
an dieses fenstern hat dann mit seiner
faust dagegen geschlagen und das ist ein
carbons gewesen also kann es davon
ausgehen thriller ist also sechsmal
starker als ein bodybuilder
erschrickt man sich auch wenn man weiß
dass diese panzer schreiber dabei ist
wäre also es ist schon sehr
beeindruckend und trotzdem dann muss man
sagen meine tiere im zoo immer irgendwie
leid also ihre ja ehrlich ist also im
aquarium naja gut okay aber fische hatte
auch nie einer gefragt wie es denn da so
läuft und wie es da so geht mir aber
diese branche auch alle verschieden naja
es gibt ja ich hab ich habe hier ein
großes aquarium sohn ich habe da zum
beispiel ein welt seit ich die narbe da
war der kleine ist sehr vielleicht zu 15
zentimeter der bewohnt ein terrain von
30 x 30 cm ja in einem 800 liter
aquarium
also der macht nur im grunde genommen
von 60 70 litern überhaupt gebraucht
ich kann nicht erkennen dass das keine
artgerechte haltung soll er wie ein
wildes tier verlässt der verlässt sein
territorium nicht frei ja genau diesen
welt stelle ich mir als glücklichen
menschen vor das ist richtig das würde
ich immer so unterschreiben wenn ich
dass der student die organistin seiner
sonne
keine unterversorgung keyboards
stress sechs metern zum beispiel
eisbären immer leid ich habe ich habe in
der arktis oft eisbären gesehen wirklich
in freier wildbahn und wenn du mal sie
ist welche normen strecken solche bären
zurücklegen das ist das natürlich
unglaublich beeindruckend doch wie
raffiniert die jagen usw es werden
markus gehören nicht in den zähnen knut
her und es gibt zwei gründe die dagegen
sprechen
bären sind sowieso ein problem weil das
uns die augen sind in für die bären die
nase genau wie beim und auch wo das wäre
noch besser riechen als hunde wären
können bis zu sieben kilometer weit wie
ich ja es ist wahr ich jetzt stell dir
einen bär wie im frankfurter zoo oder im
kölner zoo vor beim kölner zoo da gibt
es die zone und dahinter läuft die
riehler straße das und quasi ein
autobahnzubringer da ist eine
sechsspurige straße was er da rein
abgasen in seine nase geht ja lässt
natürlich jeden bären verblöden das
zweite ist bei eisbären speziell du hast
das ja gerade erzählt dass sie so weit
wandern ja jetzt kann man sagen ja das
machen die auch gar nicht freiwillig das
machen die anfahrt wegen des
jahreszeitenwechsel sowie das eis
schmilzt müssen wieder weg so jetzt ist
aber das große also nicht er muss nicht
1000 kilometern aber der eisbär muss und
der weiß dass er muss und jetzt etwas
gespenstisches auch eisbären im zoo
geboren wurden vielleicht schon in der
dritten vierten generation entwickeln
den wander trieb und dann fangen die im
frühjahr immer an den und her zu laufen
und sich über die eigene achse zu drehen
eine bewegung die in der natur so nicht
vorkommen ja schlimm also denkt dann in
diese sphären einer das eis derzeit mit
der hand
nur aus stäben besteht also die die sind
mal lade im kopf
und deswegen muss man einfach weiter aus
ich bin ja ein befürworter grundsätzlich
von zoes also meine ganze leidenschaft
stammt ja eigentlich eher aus trotz
nicht so sehr aus haustieren aber man
muss ganz ganz genau gucken unter
welchen bedingungen und man muss bei
bestimmten tieren sagen die halten wir
nicht da gehört zum beispiel der finne
dazu und da gehören auch eisbären hat
etwas mit tigern
meine dinge haben wir auch gigantische
räume aber sind so akut vom aussterben
bedroht können aber in so ziemlich gut
gezüchtet werden absolut übrigens die
meisten großkatzen gibt es wenige
ausnahmen nebelparder ist ein bisschen
schwierig deswegen dass das und ich hat
man ja ein echtes moralisches dilemma
naja so wird man benennt das ja geht die
zu sehen dass eine genetische reserve
sie sagen also es gibt in der welt noch
die zahlen schwanken ja immer ein
bisschen zwischen 200 und 300
freilebende sibirische tiger sie leben
in der taiga von sie schotter liegt
woanders gibt es keine mehr so muss sich
ja nur mal vorstellen unter diesen
bestand bricht irgendeine krankheit aus
oder es gibt eine kriegerische
auseinandersetzung oder irgendwas auch
immer uns oder dann sind die tiger der
welt weg und es ist schon schwierig
diesen bestand überhaupt adäquat zu
bewachen so und jetzt könnte man ja
sagen ist das nicht gut dass die zoos
die züchten ja diesmal züchten die die
damit selbst wenn in der natur was
passiert genug da sind die man im
prinzip wieder auswildern könnte genau
darum jetzt kann man sagen dann gibt es
erfolgsgeschichten das gefährt der schon
im rhythmus beispiel oder die arabische
oryx antilope in der natur ausgestorben
aber wieder ausgewählt hat ist
beim tiger schwer
ist vielleicht nicht gänzlich unmöglich
aber unglaublich schwere mühselig wer
bringt ihm das jagen wieder war eben
also ebenso werden ja ost ihren rentner
und wir vermenschlichen sie ja auch in
regelmäßigen sie gehalten und diese sich
nicht mehr jagen müssen und so weiter
und das ist natürlich bei raubkatzen
wirklich nicht einfach
kann sich der vorstand aber sagt man
sich ist das nicht gut dass es den tiger
noch gibt und da muss man dazu sagen
natürlich nicht für den tiger dem ist
das letztlich egal also ob seine art
ausstirbt das kapiert er nicht hatte er
kennt ja nur sein individuelles
schicksal nach sondern es ist vielleicht
so dass menschen denken wie schade ist
denn skandinavischen tiger ja also wenn
du wenn du ich weiß ich ich habe vor
einiger zeit in so einem großen tierpark
mal so ein schneeleoparden gesehen
leibhaftig
unvorstellbaren raum grünen
unvorstellbar gegen kannst du zum
beispiel in der natur nicht sehen ja
genau das meine ich wenn ich ein möglich
nach denen den kriegst du nicht zu
gesicht du kannst in den himalaya ziehen
du wirst ihn nicht sehen da ist
interessant ist auch
interessant wenn nur wenn du in afrika
unterwegs bist wenn du mal sowas ja
nicht so ein leoparden wirklich bei der
jagd gesehen hast und wie er dann diese
dieser antilope dann hochzieht auf dem
baum und dann da oben sitzt wie der king
of koppel und und sich und sich
gemütlich diese antilope einverleibt das
ist wahnsinnig beeindruckend das zu
erleben
so nahm uhr tiger bist und muss damit
rechnen dass immer mal putin durchs bild
reitet mit nacktem oberkörper das will
man ist vielleicht auch nicht ja aber
soll er deswegen aussterben damit er
sich dieses bild erspart
es richtig ist richtig aber nicht sagt
ihren artensterben ich meine wir reden
zu viel über klimawandel wo gerade dabei
sind artensterben mich hat dieser tage
bei den kollegen derzeit wie die hamas
eine auflistung gemacht wie sehr dieses
artensterben bereits begonnen hat und
jetzt reden wir nicht über tiere die wir
alle gar nicht kennen und und das geht
alles ganz heimlich vonstatten sondern
wir reden über tiere von denen wir alle
auch sagen ach mensch das sind doch
diese knuddelige in süßen tiere
schildkröten zum beispiel wusstest du
dass schildkröten männermangel haben
ja weiß warum
also die die weibchen graben am strand
dieses loch im moment jetzt
meeresschildkröten meeresschildkröten
legen bis zu 201 genau dann krabbeln die
daraus und da war dann schon die raben
geyer und so alle möglichen anderen
genauer darauf dankt beginnt sozusagen
der todeskampf auf dem weg zu mehr genau
das ist aber sozusagen die die die
natürliche auslese die da stattfindet
ist ein hartes eine hartes der minister
das auswahlverfahren aber was ich nicht
wusste ist das geschlecht dieser tiere
das wird sozusagen festgelegt durch die
temperatur das ist wie bei krokodilen
genau es häufig bei exasol also nicht
das hängt von der hitze ab ob die
männchen oder weibchen exakt so und
durch die steigenden temperaturen
passiert jetzt folgen ließ diese diese
grünen meeresschildkröten beispielsweise
da kommen fast nur noch weibchen zur
welt naja das heißt das hat unmittelbare
auswirkungen und das führt natürlich
dazu dass das diese dass diese tiere
irgendwann mal aussterben werden
afrikanische elefanten wusste ich auch
nicht
afrikanische elefanten leiden
mittlerweile unter stoßzähne mangel war
mir auch nicht klar und zwar deswegen
weil es in der natur ganz offensichtlich
immer wieder elefanten gibt die ohne
stoßzähne zur welt kommt dass das gibt
es eine laune der natur genauso wie es
sie nicht
eisbären gibt in ganz andere farbe haben
als der ganze rest usw oder auch
elefanten zum beispiel und dadurch das
waren genau gezeigt hatten und dadurch
dass die elefanten mit stoßzähnen über
jahrzehnte so gewildert worden sind hat
das dazu geführt dass natürlich
elefanten ohne stoßzähnen mit größerer
wahrscheinlichkeit überlebt haben heißt
sich auch fortgepflanzt haben heißt
diesen genetischen defekt auch quasi
weitergegeben haben heißt es kommen
immer mehr elefanten ohne stoßzähne zur
welt das ist wahnsinn oder kuckuck
wusste ich auch nicht kuckuck lebt er
davon seien eines fremden nest zu legen
kommt von zugvögeln
so dadurch dass die dass die
mit diesem milder werdenden temperaturen
und und viele arten nur noch eine kurze
zugstrecke haben
kommen die früher zurück ja das findet
alles viel viel früher stadt ja oder
erst gar nicht es gibt ganz ganz viele
die ganze team ja zum beispiel genau und
das sind so dinge
kennt man nicht albatrosse ehen
scheitern mittlerweile klimawandel sind
sowieso so treue vögeln usw aber diese
veränderten klimabedingungen lösen
partien in welche stressreaktionen und
erhöhen quasi die scheidungsrate bei
albatrosse oder oder weißes winterfeld
ist das weiß ich aus grünert das weiße
winterfell für was ich für schneehühner
aber auch für schneehasen unserem
einnahmen polarfuchs polarfüchse polar
wolf polarwölfe genau wird für die
zunehmend zum problem weil sie immer
öfter in landschaften unterwegs sind
eben nicht mehr weiß sind
also da da da da tut sich was in sachen
arten stark analysieren die ganze natur
ja so ist es ja das ist und wir
maskieren das alles um ja und eine nein
so filigranes fragiles system das sich
über jahrmillionen so herausgebildet hat
das wird uns im eiltempo durcheinander
gerührt
[Musik]
andere tiere fühlen sich wahnsinnig wohl
durch den klima arbeitet man beim
trinken wir diese ganzen krankheit zu
übertragenden mücken aus afrika hierhin
genau die musik und so was ja ja genau
so
das ist sozusagen die eine seite und die
andere seite ist das was wir machen
massentierhaltung ja es gibt übrigens
mehr tiere also jetzt großtiere
säugetier es gibt mehr säugetiere in
menschenobhut als in der natur ich
glaube ich sofort also weltweiten dix
all die millionen hühner die da gehalten
werden und so weiter schweinefarm
rinderzucht und so weiter so viele
wildtiere gibt es gar nicht mehr
wahnsinn die frage ist halt richard und
darüber wollte ich mit dir mal gedanken
austauschen was wäre das für eine welt
wenn wir jetzt angenommen wir werden
jetzt alle vegetarier oder sogar veganer
was wäre das für eine welt als
gedankenspiel als gedankenspiel normal
ich also was wäre das zum beispiel für
den landschaft durch die wir erfahren
würden also wenn du überlegst du fährst
mit deinen kindern zum beispiel durch
norddeutschland dann siehst du
glücklicher schwarzbunte kühe dann
siehst du die ganzen süßen heidschnucken
die hat die lämpchen und wird die schafe
und so weiter das würde ist ja alles
nicht mehr brauchen und demzufolge auch
nicht mehr geben er weiß was passieren
würde sagt würde verwalten es würde
verwalten gehen auch würde verwalten und
das darüber freuen verwaltung ja
verwalten verweigern da wird jahren aber
darüber freuen sich biologen nicht
uneingeschränkt weil so die
artenreichsten lebensräume sind ist
nicht der finstere tanz sondern gerade
so misch landschaften und brandenburg so
wahnsinnig viele schöne mitspieler ich
finde ja sowieso ein brandenburg ich
wollte es klar dass ich werde irgendwie
ich wollte sagt wenigen tagen in berlin
seien ja ja und werde dort vögel
beobachten irgendwo irgend solo auf was
weiß ich was ja aber in brandenburg und
dort den ganzen tag zu bringen findest
du nicht ich wollte gerade sein
brandenburg ist ein völlig unterschätzt
das land enorm unterschätzt ich will ich
würde ich würde da auch ich hab da so
ein paar pläne mit brandenburg werde ich
dürfte
also in brandenburg kann das sein dass
die rheinwiesen begegnet sind wirklich
ein wolf kann mir in brandenburg
begegnet fischotter
schwarzstorch ja fast überall
ausgestorben genau ob es noch in
brandenburg es können die er über 20
greifvogelarten begegnen brandenburg ist
so toll dass vögel die da überhaupt
nicht hingehören ja wie zwei steht der
kaiseradler der sowas kasachstan und so
weiter also rüber kommt ja der fliegt
nach brandenburg um bleibt da weil es so
schön ist
der schreiadler fliegt darum wer der
berühmte schreiadler in den streit gibt
ja und der frist die frösche der
spaziert über dem boden und hüpft und
fängt frische ja aber so großartig dass
in der natur alles zu beobachten
brandenburg ist deutschlands antwort auf
diese ihren gt was man machen müsste
wäre vor ein bisschen camps und lodges
da einrichten in brand in brandenburg ja
wahrscheinlich ja für ihre
internationalen tourismus und dann so
guided tours machen ja wurde dann
vielleicht tatsächlich ein wolf siehst
oder so was ist also das wäre eine
wahnsinnige entwicklungsperspektive und
ich bin sicher dass wir oder auch
ziemlich gut funktioniert und jetzt
kommt ein wichtiger punkt ich brauche
immer noch die bauern in brandenburg
denn wenn die felder die dazwischen sind
viele so ehemalige lpg fällt genau wenn
die nicht mehr gemäht werden usw dann
wird mir das alles nur mit weit zu
wachsen das heißt also der reiz
brandenburgs ist diese halb
kulturlandschaft das ist dasselbe ja mit
heide genommen heidelandschaften
verschwinden von natur aus ja weil sie
weil sie verwalten
und ein moor ist unter co2
gesichtspunkten ja noch wertvoller als
ein absolut werden und hier müsste man
könnte man die leute die jetzt als bauer
anders sind und jeder unter anderem auch
massentierhaltung machen die könnten
dann ganz anderen auftrag krieger die
könnten sozusagen ranger werden ja um
die semi kulturlandschaft zu erhalten
das wäre glaube ich ein richtiger
marshall-plan für brandenburg hat ja
auch an ein gigantisches potenzial wenn
du wenn du mal überlegt was auf der
einen seite gehen wir mit der natur um
wie wir damit umgehen ich habe das oft
in afrika gedacht und auf der anderen
seite sind wir bereit
das geld auszugeben damit kinder mal in
in freier wildbahn und die allermeisten
erleben das leider nie einen wilden
elefanten
eine giraffe einen wilden löwen sogar
sehen ja dass dazu sind wir auf die
anderen seite bereit ich denke dass auch
oft wenn ich dieses dieses
wahlschlachten zum teil so sehr dieser
kammer meine güte also jeder wahl der
dort im nordpolarmeer um schwimmt und
der jeden kreuzfahrttouristen komplett
zum ausrasten bringt wenn der blas dann
direkt vor seiner nase hoch geht immer
versteht ihr das eigentlich dass ein
lebender war für euch so viel wertvoller
ist island ist stichwort ja als als als
ein totales krisenländer norweger und
ich hab da drin das sind die die länder
ein zivilisiertes volk wie norweger also
norweger haben doch genau wie isländer
ja ein unglaublich gutes image in der
welt na ja also isländer jeder mag
isländer ja also mein mann denkt der
sympathien für die fußballmannschaften
und und 500 die drollig und man findet
die sprache lustig usw erfüllen so ein
bisschen so ein kindchenschema gleichen
augenhöhe rauen burschen berner also
eine mischung aus kind und wikinger so
kann so ein land noch walfang betreiben
in heutigen zeiten zu forschungszwecken
weißt du ja ja ich weiß zu
forschungszwecken da wird aber richtig
geforscht diesen worten so was von
wahlforschungsinstitut die dienste alle
gibt
und gleichzeitig aber wenn du in
reykjavik am hafen ist überall whale
watching ja ganz überall wale angucken
und das ist deswegen insofern ich komme
nur darauf weil das ist natürlich ein
interessantes auch wieder ein business
case ja wie man heute sagt mit
brandenburg finde ich total spannend
aber zurück zu den anderen punkt richard
du sagtest das würde alles verwalten
wäre also unsere kultur land genau würde
ich aber ändern es sei denn sie würden
aus anderen gründen gepflegt und man
könnte ja in die tierhaltung machen zum
beispiel schafe
die zu dem zweck da ist die landschaft
zu erhalten zum beispiel du kannst du
diese wiesen ordentlich weiter ableiten
lassen aber du würdest die tiere nicht
dazu nutzen dass du sie fern nutzt also
dass sie jetzt ist oder die kühe mails
oder so das würde im prinzip gehen also
wir reden ja jetzt nur mal über die
frage wie sich die landschaft reihe ja
genau da könnte man natürlich sagen was
bisher bauernhof mit nutztierhaltung das
wird uns in zukunft bezahlte
landschaftspflege sein das könnte man
machen so dann kommen natürlich so die
spannenden fragen was ist grundsätzlich
mit der ernährung und so weiter mit
fleisch nicht mehr aus deutschland kommt
dann kommt es aus argentinien oder gar
aus brasilien der mit der regenwald
gerodet
deswegen ist so diese vorstellung dass
man quasi aus aus deutschland ein
vegetarisches land macht oder so das ist
natürlich abwegig ja
kennst du nix senkt will
britische philosoph kollege von mir
sozusagen hängen will
ließ dem ansatz von dem vor wenn viele
menschen vegetarier oder veganer würden
dann wäre das das größte desaster dass
es für tiere jemals gab seit er ein
asteroideneinschlag die dinosaurier und
viele andere arten ausgerottet hat und
er sagt weiter
der mensch hat sozusagen sogar die
moralische pflicht
fleisch zu essen und vegetarier und
veganer sind anders rum so was wie die
natürlichen feinde all jener tiere die
gezüchtet werden um gegessen zu werden
den sie verhindern deren leben
so schade also jemand mit so einer
verqueren argumentation hätte ich gerne
mal in meiner sendung das finde ich toll
ich habe mal einmal eine sendung gemacht
mit dem klugen philosophen robert
spaemann ja der da auch das fleischessen
verteidigt hatte aber dass auch wirklich
sehr sehr lebenswerte und
nachvollziehbar und so gemeint nicht so
trudeln das ist schon richtig also wenn
die tiere jetzt alle nicht mehr gegessen
werden und man doch gleichzeitig
natürlich dann darauf achten würde dass
sich nicht vermehren
dann werden sie irgendwann eine weg ja
exempt das ist schon richtig in die höhe
also reden wir hier ja nicht über
artenschutz na also man könnte ich auch
unrat hausschweine übrig lassen und
muster bauern gelangt so gehen sondern
wir reden ja jetzt hier darüber dass die
frage sich stellt ist das leben eines
schweins so wie es heute so manchen
titeln der vater genau wirklich lebens
und bewahrens auf genau und das ist der
entscheidende punkt also das ist auch
der unterschied oder die unterscheidung
die diese denkschule sozusagen macht die
voraussetzung ist natürlich immer dass
dieses leben vorher ein gutes leben ist
also wenn du wie das ist es halt in den
seltensten fällen genau aber angenommen
das ist so dann trifft natürlich das zu
was was karl ludwig schweisfurth über
den kennst das so ja nein oder ja
pionier schweisfurth stiftung genau wie
oh landwirtschaft und so weiter metzger
war der richtig vor dem stammt er dieser
berühmte satz das mindeste was wir
schlachttieren schulden ist ein leben
vor dem tod was genau das immer genau
ich ein glückliches leben foto roth
absolut als erstes der minimalkonsens
genau das also noch das noch bevor man
sich die frage stellt nach vegetarismus
und veganismus ist das erst mal die
erste entscheidende frage genau und das
können wir bei uns nicht realisieren
also deutschland hat in was
massentierhaltung anbelangt in den
letzten 30 jahren unglaublich
aufgerüstet warum weil wir sonst für den
weltmarkt nicht mehr produzieren können
das ist wie bei allen anderen gegen auch
nur was war eine masse billig herstellt
das kann man auch günstig verkaufen und
jetzt haben wir ja noch ein
freihandelsabkommen mit südamerika das
dazu führt dass also noch mehr regenwald
abgeholzt wird weil noch mit ihr
plantagen gemacht werden weil der
absatzmarkt sich vergrößert denn wenn
man hier normalerweise fleisch aus
argentinien kauft auch übrigens aus usa
und so weiter dann ist das hier
irrsinnig teuer und zwar nicht weil es
logischerweise unbedingt ganz gut ist
sondern weil einfach unglaublich hohe
zölle drauf sind genau wenn sie
wegfallen würden dann bekäme noch
unglaublich viel mehr von diesem
massentierhaltung fleisch also was in
theater und es ist oft in argentinien
nicht aber es ist sozusagen ökologisch
enorm brutal erkauft und dem brasilien
noch brutaler kauft das gehen wir jetzt
auch noch auf unseren markt und wenn man
sich die rein ökonomische perspektive
von dem ganzen kann man auch sagen es
ist doch noch immer besser ja wir
stellen fleisch für den weltmarkt er ja
mit einem geringeren ökologischen
fußabdruck als wenn wir das zeug aus
brasilien tun das wäre jetzt sozusagen
die argumentation der deutschen fleisch-
lori
tatsächlich ist es allerdings so dass
dieses diese tiere bei uns die in der
massentierhaltung gefüttert werden mit
soja und diese so ja wieder rumdrehen
ganz auch aus südamerika und dafür
werden auch die wälder geordnetes
richtig du kannst das drehen und wenden
wie du willst dieser ganze gedanke der
massentierhaltung so oder so ist nicht
zukunftsfähig weiß weil der letzte satz
dazu wenn man sich anguckt prozentual
co2 ausstoß klimaerwärmung also
hoch ist der anteil der landwirtschaft
aber sehr hoch ist sehr sehr hoch der
ist ja viel höher als zum beispiel der
des weltweiten verkehrs einschließlich
kreuzfahrtschiffe luftverkehr
es ist tatsächlich der punkt wo man ein
ersten run müsste
der und textil und modeindustrie ja ist
auch übel aber wenn du das wirklich mal
auf schematisch stark israelis tun ich
weiß dass der größte einzel komplex ja
also industrie verkehr privathaushalte
ja und so genannte landwirtschaft das
land wird china größte klimakiller der
welt massentierhaltung
abgehakt richard ich will noch mal
sozusagen noch mal ganz
weiter runter noch grundsätzlicher
werden ja also einfach nur die frage
sollten wir tiere essen oder sollten wir
nicht christina berndt sehr gute sehr
produktive autorin von der süddeutschen
zeitung
die auch gelegentlich bei uns hinter
sendung ist
ursprünglich glaube ich wäre logan
wissenschaftsredakteurin hatten
interessanten es dazu geschrieben sehr
provokant überschrift wer tiere liebt
sollte sie essen
eine welt voller vegetarier wäre keine
gute schreibt sie da denn wer leid
verhindert indem er leben verändert
verhindert auch glück na ja das ist
natürlich insofern albern weil es an der
realität vorbeigeht wir haben ja gerade
schon gesagt so wie die allermeisten
tiere genau unter diesen sind eben dann
meint sie aber ich finde den gedanken
aber auf der bahn das würde ich will ich
will darauf hinaus richard was würde das
sozusagen verändern also die den den
ausruf denn du hast wenn du zum beispiel
mit kleinen kindern irgendwo durch die
gegend fährt und da stehen dann diese
tür irgendwie glück nimmt er an
glückliche frau teilte kommen könnte es
doch da geben wir werden halt nur nicht
gegessen das wäre doch möglich du kannst
du ja solar als familien ausflugsziele
halten und die doch nicht leben richard
wer sollte da sie sollten dabei
subventionieren überlegt mal wie hoch
die subventionen in die fleischindustrie
sind ein bruchteil der subventionen
würde ausreichend für hinlänglich genug
höfe wo die kinder mit ihren
konfrontiert werden aber markus sich in
einer ähnlicher als du denkst die alles
entscheidende frage ist am ende nicht
für mich ob wir das tier essen oder
nicht ja ich weiß dass menschen gibt
dafür die es dass die alles
entscheidende frage für mich ist die
entscheidende frage tatsächlich diese
diese glück leitfrage und eben die frage
der lebensbedingungen weil bevor ich
soweit denke dass ich mir eine welt
vorstellen in der kein tier mehr getötet
würden stelle ich mir lieber eine welt
vor in der in dem überschaubaren raum
für den wir verantwortlich sind
möglichst wenig tierleid geschieht das
ist zumindest erstmal der ansatzpunkt
und das ist eben schon wahnsinnig
schwierig weil ich möchte hier gerne
eine sache erklären die mich so stark
daran beschäftigt und das ist ich stelle
mir jetzt mal einfach in meiner
wüstesten fantasie vor ich würde
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister und würde
es jetzt erste mir geht scherzte mir und
ich würde sagen keine kompromisse mehr
ja jetzt was er sucht wir steigen aus
der massen tieren als erstes feststellen
da es eigentlich die kompetenz hoheit
des deutschen landwirtschaftsministers
sehr klein ist es stimmt ja sondern alle
wichtigen agrarfragen ja alle wichtigen
land wirtschaftsfragen werden in brüssel
entschieden so richtig so dann müsste
man also versuchen in brüssel das
irgendwie zu bringen und dann würde man
mit seinem ausstieg sehr schnell gegen
geltendes eu-recht verstoßen weil du
kannst zwar in deutschland die
massentierhaltung verbieten im abgesehen
davon dass er auch eine millionenklage
ncr ist aber das größte problem ist die
dänen und die holländer und die polen
dürfen trotzdem ihr fleisch bei uns
einführen du hättest also nichts anderes
gemacht als die deutsche deutsche
agrarindustrie zu schwächen auf kosten
der der ebenfalls massentierhaltung
produzenten zum teil unter noch
schlimmeren bedingungen im europäischen
ausland
wie kommst du aus dem dilemma heraus
indem du ethische mindeststandards auf
eu ebene gefällt die die weit über das
hinausgehen was es bisher gibt die
kriegst du aber gegen die holländer und
auch gegen die netten denen ja groß
riesiger schweinefleisch produzent und
gegen polen ja kriegst du die nicht
durch und da ist die geschichte schon zu
ende und das ist wahr aber ich sag mal
so also da camps auf den versuch an wir
haben ja am anfang dieses gesprächs
darüber geredet was eigentlich alles
passiert ist welcher welcher gigantische
sinneswandel welche welcher in welchem
perspektivwechsel wieder vorgenommen
haben innerhalb der letzten 100 jahre
nochmal dieses dieses ethische dieses
ganz grundsätzliche dilemma ja sollte
man fleisch essen sollte man tiere essen
oder sollte man sagen wir lassen das
lieber es gibt hier diesen britischen
philosophen den ich kratze die halten es
für eine moralische pflicht nachgerade
fleisch zu essen aber das ist
kabarettistisch ihr habt findet also
wenn man ja wenn man sich tatsächlich
anschaut ja wir haben ja über die
ökokatastrophe gewählt die teile die
durch den massenhaften ja fast food
konsum von fleisch ausgelöst ist und
jetzt überlege noch mal der größte
wachstumsmarkt ja bis china im hinblick
auf den fleischkonsum selbst wenn wir in
deutschland alle veganer vegetarier
werden es kommt mehr neue fleischesser
in china dazu ja als hier sich vom
fleisch essen verschieben übrigens auch
asiaten milch verzerrt genau ja das ist
natürlich weil sie sich dass endlich
leisten können wir haben das jetzt
jahrzehnte lang überfluss gemacht er und
wieder das übliche problem wie beim
umweltschutz auch den chinesen und sagen
hier dürft nicht mal ein mal die woche
fleisch haben wo wir jeden tag fleisch
essen jedenfalls viele von uns das ist
natürlich ein ziemliches ziemliches
problem
ich habe
in diesem essay von von christina berndt
steht ein interessanter absatz der muss
ich dir mal vorlesen es hilft übrigens
auch wenig ein kompromiss bereit facto
vegetarier zu sein ja also auf fleisch
und eier zu verzichten aber milch und
käse sehr wohl zu verzehren weil man
kann keine kühe halten um sie nur zu
melken kühe geben milch nur dann wenn
sie kälbchen kriegen kälbchen wiederum
geben nur dann wieder selbst wenn das
weibchen sind was bedeutet die kleinen
bullen müssen irgendwo hin und beim
ziegenkäse zum beispiel das ist
interessant da verhält es sich genauso
und bei ziegenkäse immer beliebter wird
aber kaum jemand weil sie so süß sind
kleine zicklein ist
landet dieses recht gute fettarme
fleisch von seinen kleinen siedlung dass
du wo das landet wurden 500 hundefutter
das ist hart ja das ist wirklich h also
einziges mal grundsätzlich klar also wir
könnten hier deutschland deutlich
weniger fleisch verzehren das ist schon
möglich aber es ist der tropfen auf dem
heißen stein ist habe ich ja nun gerade
am beispiel von china hat gesagt und
deswegen habe ich natürlich seit einiger
zeit eine gewisse hoffnung gesetzt ja
auf das im labor erzeugte fleisch das
hat eine sehr sehr sehr viel bessere co2
bilanz das hat eine enorm geringe
wasserbilanz da war ja auch nicht
verkehrt ist da sagt warum ist das so ja
dass ich meine wird man sich mal
überlegen wie sie mit was man trinkt
eine kugel dass die schlachten live ist
also das ist das ist natürlich wir leben
hier die so groß ist wie viel weizen
frist das ist also das leicht raus kommt
ja wenn man das alles ausrechnet also
wie viel gemüse man in dieser zeit
irgendwie herstellen könnte um wieder
die bilanz wäre und so weiter ist das
natürlich ist wie die die
massentierhaltung eine katastrophe auch
auf der weide so und jetzt könnte man ja
sagen warum machen wir das hier nicht so
wie wir entnehmen also einer einer
kleinen zelle und vermehren die in der
petrischale mehreren stellen der
osburger ja so und das kann man ja ja
das ist vor fast zehn jahren das erste
mal gemacht worden den maastricht
kostete damals 250.000 dollar ich weiß
ja
google hat dann noch geld reingesteckt
so heute kann mark post der das gemacht
hat das heute sehr sehr viel günstiger
herstellen auch andere das heißt also
dass magie des tages fleisch ich hab'
ich überlege gerade ich hab mal in der
fernsehsendung insekten gegessen und ich
überlege gerade aufhalten muss gleich
dabei ich kann mich jetzt gar nicht mehr
daran erinnern weil die frage ist wie
das schmeckt ja also die wie das
schmeckt ist relativ einfach zu
beantworten das ist wie beim fleisch
auch das kommt drauf an was man für
macht wie man es sonst
also wenn man das in einem sehr leckeren
öl macht und wenn man das entsprechend
wird und so weiter schmeckt das auch gut
also da ist jetzt nicht so ein riesen
geschmacksunterschied also vereinigen
jetzt nicht wir gehen jetzt nicht von
dem besten von den oberen und wir reden
jetzt nicht von den patagonischen drin
was hier so lecker finden sondern wir
reden von ganz schlicht normal
massentierhaltung sind da schmeckt
sicherlich nicht besser als der bürger
aus der petrischale da ist auch kein
gesundheitsrisiko dabei und so weiter
als spricht es gibt eigentlich nichts
was dagegen spricht das einzige ist sehr
aufwendig weil das muss enorm gekühlt
werden sondern sind noch sehr
energieintensiv aber irgendwann kommt
der tag da ist das günstigen als
massentierhaltung und das ist dann der
tag des gipfels das heißt es wird dann
immer noch leute geben die wert darauf
legen dass ein echtes tier auf dem grill
schmeißen aber so für den alltags
fastfood verzehr von fleisch so diesen
ganz herkömmlichen gedankenlosen verzehr
von fleisch könnte dadurch ersetzt
werden das ist durchaus möglich also
wenn man mal guckt die sind von 250.000
jetzt vielleicht auf 25.000 25 runter
kann auch dass ihr das dauert nicht mehr
lange das enorm über jahre dann ist das
günstiger ich finde ja du hast ja mal
was ganz fieses gemacht ich glaube in
einer sendung und haben interview dass
du jemanden mit folgendem gedanken
experiment konfrontiert also angenommen
da wird jetzt irgendwie nicht nur riesch
enkel haben ja das frage mit herrn
spaemann genauso was für ein mieses
gedankenspiel also ich gehe ja im spiel
war er war ja wenn es nur ums essen geht
müssen wir die tiere ja nicht töten
genau na ja und ich hab ich habe diesen
alten herren dann gesagt wir fahren
jetzt so einem befreundeten förster oder
jedes mal ja ja und er hat ja so ein
großes weiter grundstück und da gibt es
so und dann kann er sich ganz frisch
also wie man sich den humor im aquarium
rausholen kann ja ja kann man sich in
ruhe aussuchen ja und wenn die rehkeule
zu haben und dann wird das betäubt und
dann wird eben ein bein amputiert und
das kann man damit nach hause nehmen das
wäre doch besser als das ganze tier zu
töten weil das kann dann halt noch so
halb glücklich werden ohne dieses bein
wir müssen hier vielleicht nicht die
ganzen tiere essen und teile davon
und dann würde dieses reh auf drei
beinen den
regenwald leben und versuchen glücklich
zu werden ja so wenn man das immer so
machen würde dann wäre ja nicht mehr so
viel tod ihm spielen ich hoffe dass wir
in den ordnung wäre und ich weiß dass
wir dann so ein gesichtsausdruck macht
als hätte er etwas verfault und
fühlte sich sichtlich nicht wohl und
erzählte mir eine geschichte
und zwar erzählte er mir die geschichte
des bibers er hatte einen freund der in
china war und der auf der speisekarte
bieber entdeckt hat und der sich gesagt
hat pieper habe ich noch nie ich bin
davon nix fies ich bestelle mal die
bibel dabei sich wieder schmeckt so und
dann kam die an seinen tisch mit einem
lebenden bieber ja um diesen zu zeigen
dass da noch ganz frisch jetzt so was
süßes liefer und die vorstellung dass
der jetzt für ein getötet wird und er
hat dann tatsächlich den leben in bieber
gekauft und hatten an einem zoo
gestiftet
das ist ja das ist so dem mal der große
unterschied das meiste fleisch essen
basiert auf einer großen abstraktion
absolut dass wir uns das leiden den tod
und seine idee mir nicht vorstellen das
ist glaube ich ein ganz wesentlicher
bestandteil ja das ist genau also die
vorstellung dass das mittel bei paris in
der tiefkühltruhe wächst ja und das ist
sozusagen die idee aber der punkt es
gibt eine interessante geschichte dazu
wenn du mit mit grönländischen jägern
zum beispiel sprichst könnte man ja
sagen war das ist echt brutal seine arme
im nordpolarmeer einfach zu schießen und
dann irgendwie nach hause zu ziehen und
dann dort mit in diesem haus
zu brechen aufzumachen und so weiter und
die eingeweide raus und so und dann das
gegessen und hoher robben leber und so
weiter ist eine spezialität der alten
inuit gewesen hast du das mal gegessen
oder ja absolut
november heißt es immer schmeckt nicht
gut
robbe schmeckt so ein bisschen traurig
so zwischen fisch und fleisch und robbe
gibt es ja in unzähligen arten ja wie du
das machen kannst und je nachdem wie du
das costa trifft eigentlich das zu was
du geschrieben hast kann man das
natürlich essen gar keine frage also
robbens steak sozusagen mit mit mit mit
kartoffeln dazu oder so und gemüses kann
man absolut essen und wenn du wenn du
hunger hast großartig und ich meine
musste vorstellung du lebst in einer
welt in der ja gar kein gemüse wächst
also immer eine inuit
angriffs waren immer das klassische
beispiel dafür den höheren regionen gibt
die der milliarden ich hätte mir sie
dringen können einer kann die tiere
gegessen hätte genau wichtiger dass
heute lockt wieder eine idee fand er
muss man gucken also für alle vielleicht
nicht mehr zutrifft aber im prinzip ist
das so und dann kann man immer sagen ja
aber wir sind keine idriz wir können uns
auch ausgewogen ernähren ohne tiere
töten zu müssen
wenn du dann mit den leuten sprichst und
kommst dann so mit dieser moralkeule ja
und sagt hier diese armee süße robbe
dann kommt er und zwei meter
hähnchenkeule und sagte pass auf ich
habe aber bei euch im fernsehen in
dänemark habe ich gesehen wie es auf
euren schlachthöfen zugeht
massentierhaltung ein indem inuit kann
es da keine vorwürfe machen aber ich
habe noch eine frage zu der ob ich liebe
ja diese gedankenspiele
wenn du hast ja die robbe gegessen naja
wahrscheinlich auch kein schlechtes
gewissen fühlt sich ein bisschen wie so
in ruit und so erklären wenn das ich
nehme an dass robbenbabys zarte sind als
würdest du auch ein robbenbaby essen so
ein kleines weißes pelziges
ja ich will nur wissen ja würdest du
essen gut
doch am liebsten noch 41 aus und das ist
mit dem getötet also erschlagen hat da
kommt wieder der selbe bei stopp stopp
stopp stopp stopp stopp stopp stopp das
was du machst ist das was ehrlich sagt
greenpeace die gut gemeinten kampagnen
auch immer gemacht haben in grünland
wurden nie robbenbabys erschlagen die
mitmachen das nicht nein wir haben die
kanadier sind große vorgeschichte ich
weiß darüber rede ich gar nicht ich will
nur wissen jeder hat auch seine grenzen
wo er sagt ja das ist in ordnung und
wenn die tiere so richtig süß der ich
weiß dann wird es schwierig weiß ich
sage dir wo die sind ich ich kann zum
beispiel wir hatten früher mal zuhause
kaninchen ich kann absolut kein
kaninchen essen abend ich auch nicht
nein das ist völlig unmöglich ich kann
kann sich aber ungerecht war helga ist
ja keine moralische kategorie nein
natürlich nicht ich meine auch die das
alte argument ich esse nur hässliche
tiere das bringt zeit auch nicht als
macht an dem punkt nicht glück aber wie
wäre es nämlich dem argument man ist nur
die tiere die man auch bereit wäre
eigenhändig zu töten das ist ein gutes
argument und dann werde ich morgen
vegetarier na ja ist so und du würdest
dich gut dabei fehlen weil du bewusst
darauf verzichtet die tiere zu töten so
würde es funktioniert mich kriegst du da
sowieso ich bin ich bin jemand ich esse
gerne fleisch aber ich versuche den
fleischkonsum wirklich möglichst zu
reduzieren
einfach weil ich all diese themen sehe
und weil mir das klar ist absolut klar
und ich würde gerne ich habe das auch
schon oft erzählt ich ich wäre gerne
vegetarier die bittere wahrheit ist der
geist ist willig aber das fleisch
entdeckt als zu stark ab einen der römer
beiden berückende arzt in der
aufklärungszeit herunter der hat gesagt
das tragische für die tiere besteht
darin dass die frage ob es legitim ist
fleisch zu essen oder nicht zumeist bei
einem rinderbraten entschieden wird ja
ja genau so ist aber du hast diese
zahlen gesagt na also die 7,5 millionen
vegetarier genau und eines kleidung
millionen in veganer als ich zum ersten
mal ein buch geschrieben haben und das
verhältnis von mensch und tier das war
im jahr 1996
da gab es wahrscheinlich keine 10.000
veganer in deutschland
und ich habe das wort vegan erst in dem
zusammenhang kennen gelernt wenn man mit
anderen leuten darüber redet dann war
noch von den wagons die rede also dass
irgend sowas neumodisches aus amerika
oder sowas ist bei uns eigentlich gar
nicht gab und viele von diesen veganern
gehörten der radikalen tierrechtler
szene hatten ja also nicht tierschützer
sondern hier rechne also die für die
rechte der tiere gekämpft haben und die
in jeder form des fleisch essen smart
sehen und da gab es eben menschen die
quasi um eine radikale ethische position
vertraten und wir waren eben auch
veganer dass das mal als lifestyle
phänomen die die hipster kultur der
städter hinziehen würde ja
dass es menschen gibt die in ihrer
freizeit bienenzüchter sind und
gleichzeitig will ja nicht einmal hinter
ja ja ja aber auf den dachterrassen in
williamsburg ja ja von mir aus am
prenzlauer berg oder so das war damals
noch ganz ganz ganz weit weg sonst hätte
ich damals in dem buch schon einen
fliegen so zu prognostizieren dass das
vielleicht die zukunft sein könnte
fühlte ich mich im jahr 1907 19 richtig
verwegen als ich das buch dann vor
einigen jahren überarbeitet hat da
musste ich sie hin die er endlich mal
was so ein bisschen in die richtung
gelaufen wie ich es erwartet habe aber
zum schluss mache ich letzter gedanke
wir haben ja menschenrechte
darf die sehen wir auch sehr stolz weil
es genau genommen sind wir wir sind ja
auch tiere wie sieht trockennasenaffen
er wolle ja ja ja sie trockennasenaffen
also wir unterscheiden uns eigentlich
wie sie einfach nur ein anderes tier ja
wenn man dieser logik folgt damit würde
man doch sagen müssen konsequenterweise
müssen auch die anderen tiere ja die
nicht wir sind wir sind auch tiere aber
da gibt es noch andere tiere dann
müssten die doch auch rechte haben
menschenrechte für und tiere ja aber
keine menschenrechte sondern die recht
ja ich schon klar 937 kirchen sein
pläsierchen
ja also dieser dieser gedanke wird ja
auch formuliert das ist das was die
tierrechtler so sehen und zum
lackmustest des ganzen hat man ja schon
seit mitte der 90er jahre die forderung
gemacht ob man nicht zumindest den
großen menschenaffen ja ob man denen
nicht zu mindestens die grundrechte
gewährt also recht auf körperliche
unversehrtheit
was bedeutet dass man also menschenaffen
ich für laborversuche benutzen kann so
das mögen oder das recht auf
freizügigkeit also sich aussuchen können
wo sie leben wollen dann könnte man sie
nicht mehr im zoo oder im zirkus halten
und diese forderung gibt es seit mitte
der 90er jahre und da ist auch immer
wieder und den neuen anläufen darüber
diskutiert worden fakt ist dass in
deutschland keine menschenaffen mehr für
die medizinische forschung genutzt
werden fakt ist aber auch dass es nach
wie vor erlaubt wäre es wäre erlaubt ja
ja also wenn meines wissens ja also ich
hätte ihn nicht mitgekriegt dass es
wirklich verboten ist es ist eigentlich
eher so quasi ausgesetzt es gibt länder
die das die diesen menschen reifen
tatsächlich grundrechte eingeräumt haben
neuseeland zum beispiel tut das wird da
durfte man grundsätzlich dann so etwas
nicht tun also mann dürfte sie nicht im
so halten ich weiß nicht wie viel zu oft
neuseeland gibt aber auf jeden fall
keine menschenaffen und man dürfte es
auch nicht für tierversuche benutzen in
deutschland wäre das so man stelle sich
vor wir bekommen eine neue pandemie
und wir hätten im kampf gegen das virus
wird mit ärzte an raten wir müssten
dringend versuchen mit menschenaffen
machen dann könnte ich mir vorstellen
dass wenn das ist ein sehr gefährliches
virus ist eine mehrheit der bevölkerung
dafür wäre obwohl sie jetzt sich das gar
nicht vorstellen können dass so was
geschieht ja ja wir konnten uns auch
nicht mehr vorstellen alte
kohlekraftwerke wieder anzuschmeißen und
was tun wir gerade wir werfen alte
kohlekraftwerke an aber es ist trotzdem
interessant auch da nochmal letzter
gedanke ich hatte also sammer selbst
wenn die politik im zweifel
hinterherhinkt du erinnerst dich auch
dieses diese ganze frage auch julia
klöckner als landwirtschaftsministerin
der freiwilligkeit gesetzt sagen so
läuft das nicht mehr genau frei der hat
ja wenn man verbessere ist ja nichts
darauf daran wenn du appelle macht und
auf freiwilligkeit sei also ein gewisser
menschheits fortschritt ist allein über
freiwilligkeit nicht zu erzielen ist
richtig also rein freiwillig ist
kinderarbeit nicht verboten worden und
so rein freiwillig den sklavenhaltern zu
sagen 'hör mal mit den sklaven da hier
in den südstaaten das ist auch jetzt
ungewöhnlich gut doch mal auf der mit
oder so da haben die den vogel gezeigt
also allein über freiwilligkeit sind
solche sachen nicht zu machen das meine
ich arbeite dran doch keine abstimmung
unter männern gemacht ob sie das
frauenwahlrecht begrüßen die freiwillig
den jahren das recht ein so läuft das
nicht ja ja du siehst du lebst ja auch
keine metzger dazu ein gutachten darüber
zu schreiben wie toll es ist vegetarier
zu sagen gehabt ideen kommt ja auch
keiner aber die aber die was ich nur
worauf ich nur hinaus wollte ist
interessant ist was trotzdem passiert
selbst wenn politik ist noch nicht
versteht was dann gesellschaftlich
trotzdem voran geht und das sozusagen
gesellschaftliche ächtung ist danach
echt ein starker faktor der der wirklich
menschen dazu gehört um zu denken aber
mit echten moralkeule und so ist das ja
auch einmal schwierig also meinem mann
werfen man wirft dann auch gleich so
viel zusammen also in diese die rechte
die haben dann regel regelmäßig wie das
damals hieß max karrieren gemacht ja das
heißt also steine im metzgerei schau
fenster geschmissen oder mit blut
geschwitzt und dann weißt du doch gar
nicht wer ist denn derjenige auf der
anderen seite wo kommt testen fleisch
her was hat er im film verhältnis dazu
und so weiter also du zwings team in dem
moment deine moral auf von dem du denkst
dass deine moral maßlos überlegen
gegenüber seiner ist und so läuft das
auch nicht und ich meine ich gehe noch
mal auf den ausgangspunkt zurück also
warum die radikalste möglichen
forderungen stellen im hinblick auf die
rechte für jedes recht oder
vegan als einzig denkbare moralisch
vertretbare lebens zeitung es würde doch
schon unglaublich viel glück in die welt
gesetzt wenn die leute kein fleisch aus
massentierhaltung in deutschland mehr
kaufen würden das wäre doch schon mal
ein richtig guter schritt jetzt weiß ich
der eine oder andere denkt sich der
brecht hat leicht reden ja ist ein
preisunterschied und so weiter aber auf
der anderen seite ich meine ich habe ja
noch sehr lange zeit über sehr wenig
geld verfügt und habe in dieser zeit
sehr wenig fleisch gegessen
und auch damals schon weil ich mich
damit beschäftigt das pferd darauf
gelegt dass das wenige fleisch was ich
damals gegessen habe dass das ebenfalls
ich weiß wo es herkommt an dass kein
massentierhaltung ist machbar ist was
alles schon
daniel kehlmann 2006 auf die frage
worüber werden wir in 200 jahren lachen
oder staunen dass wir tiere in fabriken
gehalten haben das wird es in 200 jahren
nicht mehr geben das ist richtig ich
glaube nicht dass wir 200 jahre warten
müssen ich habe übrigens vor 34 jahren
einen vortrag gehalten in frankfurt auf
dem mitja also mit ist eine messe wurde
nicht wo man sich begegnet soll man die
fleisch messe in frankfurt und habe
denen erzählt an ihrer stelle würde ich
jetzt nicht mehr in den massen
tierhaltern ich würde an eurer stelle
jetzt nicht mehr ganz groß investieren
und versuchen eure
tierproduktion zu intensivieren sondern
ich würde den schwenk machen eben auf
die fabrikation von von sauberem fleisch
also fleisch wird dass keine tiere oder
fast keine tiere sterben ist
und ich habe es da mit nachdenklichen
menschen zu tun habt also das
ökonomische argument überzeugt auch
diejenigen die für moralische argumente
nicht zugänglich sind ich habe übrigens
den erlös geht nicht da bekommen habe
mein honorar fehlt beim für den verein
gegen tierfabriken gestiftet
also die haben mich danach auch häufiger
nochmal appelliert habe ich nicht noch
mehr vorträge halten wird
vor einschlägig und pia und es erinnert
mich an luisa neubauer die gerne
vorträge von vertretern der deutschen
bank hält und geißelt das nach wie vor
co2 intensiven industrien in anderen
ländern gefördert werden oder fracking
gefördert wird in den usa zum beispiel
oder mit kapital mit krediten versorgt
wird und das hören sie sich offenbar
auch gerne an das ist so dass das
touristische in uns ja aber hier ging es
gar nicht mal so hoch ist muss man dazu
sagen ja sondern um die überlegung ob
das alte geschäftsmodell noch
zukunftsfähig ist weil es keine 200
jahre brauchen wird bis das nicht wenn
ja und interessant ich komme ja immer
wieder stimmen punkt zurück ich glaube
unsere kinder spielen dabei eine
gigantische rolle ich wenn nicht sogar
die rolle bei diesem paradigmenwechsel
den wir da gerade auch angesprochen
haben ich erinnere mich an ein gespräch
mit herbert diess hat im dem vw chef der
so konsequent wie kein anderer in
deutschland auf elektromobilität setzt
und das auch sehr früh ganz krass
angesagt hat auch getrieben natürlich
von diesem diesen skandal den vw hatte
und so weiter aber nichtsdestoweniger er
hat es gemacht und
damals zu mir auf die frage woher denn
die intrinsische motivation bekommt sagt
und airlines machen sie mal nichts vor
ich bin zwar der vw-chef aber bei mir zu
hause am tisch und frühstückstisch
dasitzen grünen wähler ja
dass das erklärt glaube ich sehr sehr
viel ich glaube manchmal ist die welt
ganz einfach ja man man man sagt ja
immer der vietnam krieg wäre in den
amerikanischen wohnzimmern verloren
worden es könnte auch sein dass die
schlacht um die massentierhaltung ja an
den frühstückstischen die sache publik
im austausch mit den eigenen kindern
richtig ja ich glaube dass es so ist
richard ich danke dir sehr dass zwar
viel gelernt heute fallen die über deine
leidenschaft für führt aus ich sehe dich
seit heute noch mal mit ganz anderen
augen dank dir sehr verhindern direktor
perfekten also passt ist das motto
eine produktion von mpeg 2 und hot fuzz
bei on air im auftrag des zdf
[Musik]